today President Trump get this he fired
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson on
Twitter he fired him on Twitter yeah
yeah it makes sense when you consider
that Trump hired Tillerson on tinder
that's how they met
[Applause]
Rex Tillerson reportedly doesn't know
why he was fired yeah at least that's
according to sources roommates Sean
Spicer and Omarosa
they have no idea a triple bet yeah
thank you one guy one of the nipple
rubbers was like oh yeah that's that's
worth something yeah now they're
invested in your success exactly yeah
pretty smart huh I got them emotionally
involved under President Trump
abstinence only education is making a
comeback yeah or as Trump told teenagers
do as I say not as they paid some
$130,000 to shut up
[Applause]
60 minutes just interviewed Betsy DeVos
and they're about to interview stormy
Daniels yeah that's right two women
equally qualified to be education
secretary Game of Thrones fans here I'm
sure you do
HBO HBO has hinted that the final season
of Game of Thrones will include many
many deaths yeah
in fact HBO said if they run out of Game
of Thrones characters they'll have to
start killing people on the show ballers
nothing huh okay it's too late now if I
ask for it it's no good yeah I think I
think they may be ballers fans and their
concerns yeah strange thing to say last
week last week major league baseball
team the Kansas City Royals hope this
guy over here it's like uh last week
major league baseball team the Kansas
City Royals hosted an anti porn seminar
yeah
no one attended
[Applause]
you